cette archive elle est d'autant plus
précieuse et et forte pour moi qu'elle
révèle qu'elle révèle au public surtout
la l'importance de cette femme dans le
mouvement
Emmaus même dans des moments où le
tourment de ne pas avoir la tendresse
féminine je le ressentais très fort
c'était un chef alors cette archive
montre des images inédites de Lucy
Coutaz qui a étéit une une grande
résistante et qui a aidé l'abbé Pierre
et elle l'a accompagné 40 ans de sa vie
dans son combat de la création d'maus et
dans tout ce combat quotidien contre la
misère il y a des compagnons d'Emmaus
qui évoque son souvenir et qui parle
d'elle comme un chef et d'une femme qui
à la fois était tendre mais aussi avait
beaucoup d'autorité tout le monde
l'aimait bien parce que on savait que
saercite rudesse et qu'elle c'était une
femme de cœur et tout le monde l'a
respecté malgré qu'on l'appel l la
terreur si US existe c'est un peu
beaucoup à elle ce qui est très amusant
dans cette dans cette archive c'est que
l'abbé Pierre évoque lui aussi Lucy
Coutaz qu'il était aussi ébahi ahuri
qu'il n'y ait jamais eu comme il le dit
de problèm masculins féminin entre Lucy
et lui pendant 40 ans de vie côte à côte
parce que vraiment il se brossaient les
dents ensemble dans la la première
communauté Emmaus à neu plaisance ils
ont été en colocation ils ont vraiment
vécu côte la côte et il n'en revient pas
qu'il ait pas eu que cette cette
relation est soit restée platonique j'ai
vécu 39 ans jour et nuit sous le même
toit avec les mêmes embêtements les
mêmes bonheurs et cetera il n'y a pas eu
mais pas eu c'est mystérieux mais il n'y
a pas eu un instant de problème masculin
féminin je crois pas plus de son côté
que du mien et je trouve ça assez
merveilleux puisque cet Abé pierre en
fait on le connaît pas si bien il est il
c'était un charmeur aussi ce qui est
très touchant dans cette archive c'est
qu'en effet on le voit lui-même un peu
rigoler un peu comme on le voit jamais
comme il apparaît jamais dans les médias
et là de le voir ce ce petit monsieur à
un certain âge avouer que qu' leur vient
pas qui a pas eu de problèmes masculins
féminins et qui trouve ça formidable
c'est c'est très touchant et de le voir
rire lui en fait et au fond elle a été
mon euh
certainement en grande partie
euh ma protectrice
car quand elle voyait quelqu admiratrice
qui avait tendance un petit peu trop
vouloir me
posséder bon elle savait chasser les
mouches
oui elle était elle était extrêmement
vigilante pour la protection de ma
vertu au dire de de de ceux qui l'ont
connu on le voyait jamais rire et donc
là de de le voir un peu se se gosser
comme ça se être un petit peu secoué de
de de rire je trouve que ça ça
l'humanise encore plus et ça lu donne un
charme fou ouais et cette archive elle
est d'autant plus précieuse et et forte
pour moi qu'elle révèle qu'elle révèle
au public surtout la l'importance de
cette femme dans le mouvement Emmaus et
et elle lui disait toujours mais vous
êtes fou et elle finissait toujours par
le suivre donc il y avait une fidélité
un respect immense l'un pour l'autre
mais elle était quand même elle jouait
ce ce rôle parfois de de celle qui
recadrait qui faisait l'administratif
qui suivait les comptes parce que lui il
était incapable de tenir la la boutique
quoi les archives de Lina étaient très
précieuses puisque il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de matière j'avais neu stades
de vieillissement et donc je me référais
à ces archives il était command dans les
années 50 il était command dans les
années 60 70 80 surtout le travail sur
la voie aussi et donc j'ai pu vraiment
oui accéder à toutes ces interviews des
documents ex exceptionnel je suis tombé
sur cette fameuse archive qui a retenu
mon attention et que j'ai voulu vous
proposer parce que elle montre une
facette de lui qu'on ne connaît qu'on
connaît peu et il pouvait parfois parler
de lui de manière très intime très
transparente sans langue de bois et donc
je trouve ça très touchant et drôle
aussi moi j'ai éclaté de rire quand j'ai
vu cet archive
vraiment